I almost had to blow them this [ __ ]
matches Thor that's how you guys cuz the
guy was rude to my girl she was waiting
outside for social distancing when two
other [ __ ] was getting their matcha
and then the guy tried to close the
[ __ ] place he's like she's like I've
been waiting outside from before for so
the guy was like fine come in rolled his
eyes came and made the matcha she said
made a hell of shitty so I had to go the
next day
can I be honest this is the whitest
Doria matcha
the guy rolled his eyes at the girl yeah
and then she was respecting social
distancing in every way this is the
conversation with that guy guys is a
white hate crime
don't roll your eyes dude rolling his
eyes at a girl that he just met is like
come on bro I need you to please the
next day I want to speak to your manager
no I spoke to him I went with her I said
wait outside I'm gonna go talk to his
mother [ __ ] I went I spoke to him and
I said yo yo it's my girl's birthday
just go out there just wave like that
anyways get my girl yo yo thank you
appreciate it
I by the matzah and I was a yup do you
learn a lesson I mean waved at me is
that yeah I told her to apologize and I
was like you gotta look at be nice
matter what so that's what happens
sometimes you teach a lesson she gotta
know who the [ __ ] you know King yo
you let him know I'm out here what
really happened nothing
we went back I was a [ __ ] are we
outside with the electric bike man
I can't let this
you don't even call it a motorcycle it's
a my it's a bike bro it's an electric
bike what am I supposed to do I'm
supposed to knock this guy out for being
completely reasonable my girl showed up
at four you know I can't tell my girl
she's wrong with quarantine I'm in this
[ __ ] conflict I'm biking house fall
trying to put all pieces together we get
me a goddamn spot I would not but there
are cots gonna make fun of me punish
[ __ ] do the [ __ ] I do already
no tipping the [ __ ] barista
infuriates me I got tip you before you
do your job oh god of [ __ ] is that every
of the whole tip system is you do your
job and then I like to service my tip
you know you got him started on tips
bacha do to fight him for you hey unless
you and me go talk to this guy
we're rolling your eyes at yo so usually
that's the unnecessary part can I be
honest with you though Ezra you gotta
find a situation yeah you gotta find
anything be like a man I get it but like
you're and after all your eyes like I
don't know that I don't know how to do
that
oh because if someone's rude to your
girl in a certain point you can be like
I kind of get it you know oh there's
never a point where I don't get it
there's never a point out of rudeness I
completely understand man physical [ __ ]
does different yeah but the guy is at
work get in corona every day he's about
to close up the shop and then he sees
another person outside that's worth I
roll in your bucket you're buggin
you just sleep over this he used to sell
the cream of the crop yeah let that be a
warning he told us he was gonna have
this confrontation last week show you
here he's like I've got to go I've beat
up the Macho Man I don't care judge me
this lapse you would like macho man
let's go you wanna know this what
happened I said babe hold the bike
outside she loves a bike outside I go in
there right I go yeah Lydia - oh and I
forgot [ __ ] girl warning and then she
goes out like a [ __ ] macadamia nut
I'm watching whatever I'm worried
deflated Sam macadamia nut milk right
I'm already plated to say that Damian
matcha latte let me get two of them
shits right he go to do it and I'm
waiting to have the confrontation when
he comes back right and no [ __ ] they
just started selling these like Thai
vanilla
so this [ __ ] looks so delicious right
but they're behind the counter okay oh
you gotta ask him for one so I can't
curse the [ __ ] out and then get
my Thai vanilla peanut butter cups right
so I said my girl can't hear nothing
she's outside so I can Ella so I go like
this so I go like this I go I give her
the nod like it's about to go down I'm
like yo I talked to you
he felt bad he throws a time no peanut
butter shake his hand at the end and
make it look like you really had it yeah
I mean he really patch things up
they're like babe you could go here any
time you want now it's not cool they're
what if she rude to him like what is he
rude to her again no no and we gotta
fight didn't get a war I haven't had a
fight in a while what do you mean fight
like I haven't had off like a fight like
a physic not even a pushing physical
altercation in a while no I'm not saying
that I want to have one but I'm saying I
haven't had one in a while it's gonna
happen it's the laws of the world you
have to order eight peanut butter cups
you would I would fight him you know I
love this kid is he's a tiny little
[ __ ] kid but like I mean you know
eventually there's gonna be another
fight it's only the law of inertia that
that happened dumbest logic when I was
younger if I went too long without a
fight for one because it's like I got to
make sure I'm still like you yeah make
sure you're still good and that was the
worst logic I'll go out there looking
for a foot give and see and that's where
and then you get caught by a
[ __ ] than the mantra man throw
some [ __ ] greens nationwide ever in
prison in Sweden but I don't want to get
record I was 18 3 oh yeah yeah I
remember the first time I spoke out
about that he did tell me his record and
include the losses and I was like wow
but then you believe that eight yeah he
wouldn't you got is eight he won those a
fight now know started from when I was a
kid up until not very low gonna [ __ ]
about 2017 yeah I'm [ __ ] what's it
called is that is three years at eight I
take that as a win because I connected
and if that wasn't a windy and I hunch
me with anything he hit me with a stick
yeah but he moves you like a hundred
feet how do you move me with a stick he
actually moved you much more than two
feet he moved you to a prison I got that
he legit puts you on the mat the yoga
mat they gave you and I want you to
sleep on so [ __ ] put you to the
mat they all connected and then a little
while later he dropped so I dropped him
I dropped him no I dropped them hey did
he fall or not he fell what he was
running after me when I was running away
people he had to get his people together
I mean one and we can't get this crowd
video can we mass too late that guy he's
not even a lawyer anymore
I'll try contacted oh he quit after that
case bodied him I cooked him I cooked
him in court but think about it think
about imagine you have your whole case
like you didn't watch it man real talk
imagine you got your whole case you
could pay oh hell I'm gonna take
everything I'm gonna get you over your
ears
oh he's black if you got a deserved it
took care of it not played into the race
card a little bit
you have to they got white guilt over
there yeah but I tried to like reverse
psychology them on the race card oh I
was like I don't usually see things like
this but like I was I was really trying
I leaned it but I did [ __ ] your lawyer
and maybe that's why he quit
maybe son I was out there in the [ __ ]
Ralph Lauren I pulled up in that record
Ralph
a fat [ __ ] a fat [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ]
no wasn't - the 28 days say what I said
- the 28 days I was about that that's a
vacation bro we need to get back out in
the road and they have [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] Sweden's openness only place that
state open place the week of [ __ ]
golden show Oh
so rough one that's a rough one you
think you could talk to the club owner
for me see if I say you got to go back
to that mantra sir you got to say so
yeah you got a goal whisper in his ear
you go
I got a huge [ __ ] and then just see what
he does row then then your boss what
should I say be like look man I get it
it's tough but you can't sit here and my
girls trying to respect you got to deal
with all this [ __ ] and then you roll
your eyes at it it's just disrespectful
that's it that's all
Noby and then if he fires back me right
look man honestly you're right but I did
my job
so i'ma see you later see now I can't do
I don't understand reasonable company
too much time went by now it's too late
also next days you'd be like yo my girl
came home they were Thai vanilla peanut
butter cup yes mam but like you also
have my girl loves this [ __ ] macho
spot so I don't I already ruined one
restaurant with a past girlfriend via de
la pocha on 7th Street okay I think it
burned down it wasn't me but we went
there one time and it was an empty
restaurant I asked for this specific
table and they said no and they try to
put me another table and I said nobody's
here can we just go in this table and
they said no and then forever mortal
enemies that's the only restaurant my
dad remembers you know my dad was gone
he remembers one restaurant I refuse to
go down a gang-up I just can't
yeah that was your Michael Jordan
restaurant son loathes them eventually I
got over it but that I couldn't do this
again for her cuz she loves this macho
spots right by did you have when you get
over with the Italian restaurant a
little bit when'd you get over it around
the time and burn it down no it's right
before yeah man so I got I got to be
better at that I bet at the you know
confrontations because I don't what
you're saying is very reasonable I don't
know how to be reasonable in competition
it's just go time yeah you guys have
experienced it I don't I'm not like
defending honors overrated is the best
part about being Christian dude if some
[ __ ] happens so [ __ ] happens to my girl
I just go turn the other cheek babe goes
all right read the Bible exactly meek
will inherit the earth so be meek [ __ ]
I just don't think it's odd I think like
you have to do that when you're ready to
[ __ ] tear the house down if you're
not willing to tear the house down
don't even go about it that's a crazy
crazy statement there's no gray area at
all there so like I just feel like if
you're gonna have a confrontation you
gotta be really to burn the whole
restaurant yeah so here's example right
like I remember once this homeless guy
was like acting crazy like I think
towards up my mom or like in the area of
my mom yeah and then my mom goes Oh
and so it's like run and my dad goes
yeah calm down right he just got to calm
down because he knows that guy's not
gonna do nothing yeah but then there was
one time this car almost hit me and my
brother and I never seen my dad act out
physically ever and he just starts
slamming the hood of the corn right cuz
that's a life-or-death situation you
blow [ __ ] up the other one nothing's
gonna happen what are you getting all
[ __ ] riled up about yeah
yeah but that wasn't reasonable of him
because the car didn't hit you so why
are you gonna cause damage to the car
that didn't do anything just scared you
I wasn't reasonable but he stood up for
your honor
early early life they could have serious
damages a series of you know PTSD and
that kind of [ __ ] it's a real
ineffective you still say what has it
affected you still yeah honestly what do
you think happens I just you know
honestly I don't I don't feel
comfortable talking about emotional I
get a little choked up when I'm talking
about it y'all really gonna make me
punch this much happens and I get locked
up that's on y'all
[Applause]